good evening everyone my name is Priya
Nataraja I'm faculty in the department's
of astronomy and physics and I'm the
current director of the Frankie program
in science and humanities at Yale I'm
delighted to welcome you all to today's
talk that is part of our ongoing series
mapping as knowing throughout the series
we've been examining how mapping across
disciplines has helped chart the
frontier but between what is currently
known and what remains to be explored
before introducing today's speaker I
would like to take this opportunity to
first thank Richard and Barbara Frankie
who happened to be in the audience today
whose generosity and support of the
Frankie program has helped foster
cross-disciplinary intellectual
engagement on campus I would also like
to congratulate and give a shout out to
our newly selected graduate and
postgraduate and postdoc Frankie
research fellows and I'd like to remind
you that after the event we have a
reception in room 108 immediate
immediately following the Q&A and I'm
also required to give you all this
notice that this event is being recorded
and photographed for educational
archival and promotional purposes
including use in print on the internet
and in other forms of media by attending
this event today you agree to the
possibility of your voice or likeness
captured by these means and used for
such purposes without compensation to
you and hereby waive any related rights
of privacy or publicity now on to
today's talk as an astrophysicist myself
it gives me particular pleasure to
welcome one of my most distinguished
colleagues professor David Spergel David
Spergel is the founding director of the
Center for computational astrophysics
that forms part of the Flatiron
Institute in New York prior to heading
the Flatiron Institute and the CCA he
was the chair and Charles young
professor of astronomy at Princeton
University his research interests span
an impressive range of scales in the
cosmos from the search for planets
around nearby stars to mapping the shape
of the universe itself using
observations of the Cosmic Microwave
Background the relic radiation from the
Big Bang taken with the W Maps satellite
and data from the Atacama cosmology
telescope in Chile his work has helped
to measure the age shape and composition
of the universe these observations have
played a very significant role in
establishing the key parameters that
characterized the standard model of
cosmology he's one of the leaders of the
Simons Observatory which will include a
planned millimeter wave telescope that
will allow us to take the next step in
studying the microwave sky and probing
the history of the universe David is
also actively involved in planning
future missions including shaping the
upcoming wide field Infrared Survey
telescope w first as it's normally known
mission for which he currently serves as
the co-chair of the science team w first
is a precursor of follower to Hubble
that will map the universe at hundred
times the resolution of problem the area
not the resolution but the area he also
serves as the co-chair of the global
coordination of ground and space
astrophysics working group of the
International Astronomical Union his
list of awards and accolades is
incredibly long and in the interest of
time and not keeping you away from
hearing him I will just mention a few of
the most recent ones and you will see
how hard my task has been he was awarded
the breakthrough prize in 2018 the NASA
exceptional service medal the Dannie
Heineman prize for astrophysics the
Gruber prize in cosmology the Shaw prize
in astronomy the MacArthur Fellowship
and it goes on and on at the before I
invite him to the podium to talk to us
today about mapping the universe I just
wanted to remind you that following the
talk we will ask for usual have a Q&A
and a reception David
[Applause]
Thank You Priya it's a pleasure to be
here and a pleasure to be part of this
series what I want to do today is convey
how we have mapped the early universe
and and what we've learned from that and
it's been a remarkable adventure over
the past sub 20 or so years and it's one
that continues and as in the arc of my
talk I'll sort of want to introduce
cosmology introduce what we've learned
talk about our Maps and then look to the
future and the future kinds of maps
we're hoping to make so what will we
have we learn from the maps we've made
of the early universe we've learned that
the universe is both remarkably simple
and remarkably strange causing the
ultimate of reductionism we can describe
all the properties of the universe with
five basic numbers the age of the
universe the density of matter the
density of atoms how lumpy the universe
is and how that varies with scale and
that's you know and with that as you'll
see we can fit with precision
measurements not only of the early
universe but measurements of the
large-scale distribution of galaxies
observations of supernovae large-scale
structure all the things fit together so
this is sort of a tremendous triumph in
having a simple model fit many things
but it's a triumph that also raises lots
of questions because the simple model
implies adults the stuff that makes up
us makes up only 5% of the universe the
remaining 95% isn't stuff that we don't
understand roughly 25 percent is in the
form of what we call dark matter that's
some new particle it's something it's
not what makes up atoms it's something
we haven't discovered yet our ideas vary
from
tiny subatomic particles two massive
black holes and that's the simpler part
the remaining 75% seems to be in the
form of what we call dark energy energy
associated with empty space so when we
have a model where we don't know that
makes up 95% of it we clearly have a
tremendous amount to discover and I
think how people respond to this both
within the fields in the up side says a
lot about what how we approach
understanding there are people who are
thrilled that we have a model that fits
the people who like things to be orderly
and there are people who are thrilled
that we have so much we don't understand
because that so there's a lot to
discover and so there's a bit for
everybody in the current state of
chrismole OG to explain how he got there
the other thing I should say before I go
on is other things maps revealed and
when I took the data I showed that I'll
show it in the talk when people asked me
to summarize what we learned
long before the Nobel Prize announcement
last week my summary was the map showed
us that Jim Peebles was right and that
much of this model I'll discuss really
builds on theoretical work that he was
many people contributed but he was the
prime person who did this in from the
60s to the 80s constructed a theoretical
model that now has represents our best
fit to this data and it was I think we
were all pleased to see him award win
this prize Jim is both a great scientist
and a good person and it's nice just
what nice things have when good things
happen to nice people and I think that's
what what many of us would know him felt
about the recent prize announcement
to go to explain my story today I have
to begin by teaching you a little
special relativity the key idea of
special relativity is light travels at a
finite speed it takes light a few
nanoseconds to get from me to you so you
see me not as I am but as I was a few
nanoseconds ago it takes light about
eight minutes to get from the Sun to us
so that light coming through is hitting
people on the right-hand side yeah has
you're seeing the Sun as it was eight
minutes ago and you know when we send
communications back and forth to Mars it
will take 20 minutes favored for
information to go back and forth see
that's been solved and the further out
you go in space the further back you go
in time when we say a star is four light
years away that means we see it as it
was four years ago when a star is a
hundred light years away we see it as it
was a hundred years ago and that's
symmetric if you were on a planet
orbiting around that distant star an
observer there would see us as we were a
hundred years ago and the further out
you go in space the further back you go
in time so astronomers get to see the
universe's past when we look at nearby
galaxies we see them as they were a
million years ago and one of the things
that we learn with telescopes like
Hubble and our powerful ground-based
telescopes as we look out in space and
we see galaxies in their infancy now we
don't see our galaxies immune in this
infancy because we're looking out and
we're seeing distant galaxies but our
universe seems to be homogeneous so the
same processes are occurring occurred
here occurred out there so we can watch
galaxies form and emerge and the maps
that I will show you will primarily
reflect conditions 13.8 billion years
ago when the universe was in its infancy
and we'll look back and
the pic the maps I will show will be
maps of the universe in its infancy
effectively the universe's baby picture
and the universe in its infancy was
simple so we look at that we can infer a
great deal about the universes basic
properties everyone's good with special
relativity all right general relativity
general relativity consists of two ideas
matter tell space how to curve so you
can see the Sun curved space around it
and the curvature of space tells mass
and light edibles and the great the
first great test of this was a
measurement of how stars during a solar
eclipse but we were able to look good
stars close to the Sun things that were
actually behind the Sun their pads was
just were distorted by gravity and we
see them in a different place and this
was the test in 1919 that made Einstein
famous and really established the theory
of general relativity is our best
description once you have the theory of
general relativity and you make the
assumption which we've now tested
observational e that the universe is
homogeneous on large scales you could
find that the only allowed solutions is
to have the universe expand or contract
now this is the part that I think most
people find conceptually confusing
because most of us have a Newtonian
notion of space and if things are
expanding they think explosion
unfortunately the theory got named the
Big Bang Theory Fred oil who was an
opponent of a theory gave it its name to
kind of insult it and what the damage
he's done the foil was a great scientist
despite being wrong
was that he's left us with an image that
I think we think of an explosion
happening in a moment in space but I
think the right way to think about it is
to think about having not at a moment in
space but a moment in time and the
picture I have is I suppress one
dimension I think of us living in a
two-dimensional surface like a surface
of it like this ball here and each one
of these dots represents a galaxy and as
the universe expands the distance
between galaxies grow the universe gets
less and less dense with time now the
question many of you have is what is it
expanding into well it's expanding into
the future it's the time direction
that's expanding it we're always moving
into the future and as it we move into
the future space gets bigger
well that's bigger growing to the future
let's go towards the past as we go
towards the past the universe gets
denser and denser and eventually gets so
dense it reaches an infinite density of
we call the initial singularity that
happens not at a moment of place in
space but a moment in time that initial
singularity represents a breakdown in
our understanding when we get to the
enormous densities and temperatures at
this point we get to a point in which
our understanding of physics breaks we
general relativity and quantum mechanics
do not fit together we don't have a a
mathematically successful succinct
theory they can explain what happens at
that point
string theory probably what row
represents our current best attempt to
solve this problem it has not solved it
yet so this basically is as far as we
can go so questions like what was there
before the Big Bang was there before the
Big Bang
we don't know how to answer in a
rigorous way it is something that some
of my colleagues work on and you know
struggle to find ways of doing this but
it represents I would say beyond the
edge of what we currently understand
so that's slipped I'll just skip that
slide and give you sort of a quick
history of the universe again so let's
take that picture you can see the
universe start out very dense it also
started out very hot as it expands it
cools about 380,000 years after the Big
Bang it gets cold enough that electrons
and protons combine to make hydrogen
hydrogen is transparent to the radiation
for the Big Bang so the radiation can
travel freely from then to now so when
we look at the microwave background we
are looking at what the universe looked
like 380,000 years after the Big Bang
roughly 13.8 billion years ago the fact
that we could learn so much about it
makes us want to map the sky and see
this leftover radiation now this
leftover radiation is something that
many of you may have seen a bit of we've
heard if any of you is what watched
television before cable and you switched
your TV between channels you saw static
about one percent of that static was
coming was the microwave background it's
actually enough it's fills all space and
you could see it and when you switch
your radio between channels most of the
static is coming from the Earth's
atmosphere but about a percent or so is
coming from the early universe so if you
build a dedicated telescope that you
designed to get away from all the bad
backgrounds you can actually start to
map this out we and that's why as you'll
see we need to go to very isolated
places like mountaintops 17,000 feet
above sea level in Chile or to the South
Pole
order out to outer space to be able to
map it to get away from the static from
sources on the earth and I first want to
describe some of the stuff that I was
involved with now almost starting now
over 20 years ago
when we built a radio telescope called W
map named after our late colleague Dave
Wilkinson that we launched out beyond
the orbit of the moon to map the
microwave sky and we mapped this at
several different wavelengths and these
figures show our data you know and since
this theme here is mapping is knowing
for us the maps really represent the
best way we have of showing our data the
maps actually represent for us the first
step in our kind of reductionist program
we start with data we take for the
telescope as a telescope spins around
and it actually takes about a trillion
observations as we measure the skies
observed already we make the assumption
when we do more measurements that when
we point in that direction at the
leftover heat from the Big Bang on
Tuesday come back on Wednesday then it's
the same sky so we add our data together
and that's what lets us make a map and
so they're our first step is to make a
map like this and what represented in
the map is variations in temperature
from place to place the blue spots are
cold the green spots are a little warmer
and the red spots or a whole honey you
know one ten thousandth of a degree
hotter than the blue spots so there are
variations and temperatures of about
10,000 to the degree across this part of
the map now you'll notice this big
bright red thing but I haven't talked
about that's pretty striking
that's our own galaxy the Milky Way we
live in the galaxy when we observe we
see our galaxy we see through it at this
frequency we're seeing emission from
electrons moving in the magnetic field
of our galaxy and you could see it
dominates a lot of our image what we do
is we observe the sky at multiple
frequencies and as we go up in frequency
the galaxy gets dimmer and dimmer
reaching its minimum around here getting
slightly brighter here and we use this
multi frequency data to construct our
best model for the galaxy and remove it
I think of it as I want to look at you
know my galactic astronomer friends may
not like this analogy but I want to look
at in the beautiful scene and I've got a
smudge in my window as I look out and I
want to remove that smudge so I could
see the beautiful scene in the distance
and that's what we do we combine our
multi frequency data and we make a clean
map and this map shows our best attempt
and also better attempts with more
recent data with the data we had in this
is now back in 2003 to show the
microwave sky and these variations in
temperature from place to place
represent variations in the density and
temperature of the universe from place
to place 13.8 billion years ago and we
look at these patterns and we try to
understand what we see here perhaps the
first thing that comes to your eye is
the letters SH I first saw this when I
was sitting with my colleague Lyman
Paige in 2003 we were sitting at a talk
at UC Davis where Stephen Hawking was
speaking and behind him was a copy of
our data and Lyman turned to me and said
they put the letters si
Sheena's a joke and of course we had our
own copy of the day toner laptops we
pull it up the letters sh are there and
i think there's a lot we can learn from
this not about the early universe but
about ourselves we're very good at
finding patterns we're good at finding
patterns even if they're not
statistically significant and I view
this actually is an evolutionary a
selection effect because I imagine two
sets of ancestors one set over here
they're calm they're sensible there's
some what they see something in the
distance it's probably not a tiger 99
times out of 100 it's not a tiger then
there's these nervous jumpy people who
jump to conclusions without really solid
evidence but when they saw something
funny
they ran 99 times they ran unnecessarily
that 100 times the couple over here guys
and these are our great-great
great-great grandparents so we've been
selected to find patterns and one of the
challenges analyzing maps is you see
something like this and you have to
figure out is it significant do we learn
something from this what is the real
information contained in the map and one
of the tools and when we work in this
field we spend a lot of time doing
statistics because one of the big
challenge is understanding what is a
fluctuation what is just our eyes are
good at seeing things and what is
telling us something significant about
the nature of the universe so there as
Steven is the late Stephen Hawking and
while he was a great scientist I'm
pretty sure his initials were not
engraved in the early
versus a message to us so what do we
think we're looking at we actually think
we're looking at sound waves in the
early universe so the patterns we see we
can understand with some just really
basic physics if I create a region of
excess pressure and we'll do this
experimentally right now what happens it
sets off a family and that sound wave
propagates out and in the early universe
there's variations in density from place
to place and that creates these sound
waves and you see the sound wave and
380,000 years move a characteristic
distance which is what we call the sound
horizon how far a sound wave in the
plasma of the early universe can move
and we actually see a whole bunch of
those waves on top of each other and the
pattern you see in that map we
understand there's a combination of
these waves and one way to analyze the
data let me just put those in okay is to
go to these maps and and stack on these
hot and cold spots and if you do that if
you stack on hot and cold spots you
actually find that there's rings around
them and those rings represent the
patterns produced by sound waves another
way of seeing that in doing that so
let's go back to that circle what we're
going to do is we're going to throw down
on this map circles of different sizes
and average the temperature in that disk
and ask what is the average fluctuations
on this scale on this scale on this
scale when you see our analysis you
actually see something which you can
kind of see by eye there's a
characteristic size of hot and cold spot
that characteristic size is about one
degree those we have 40,000 of those hot
and cold spots we could measure
quite accurately that's the distance a
sound wave moves in the early universe
and because we've measured that quite
accurately we can combine that with our
measurements of the geometry of the
universe and infer the universe's age so
basically I look at that triangle there
I know this is about a degree that angle
I know that corresponds to how far a
sound wave could move and 380,000 years
that's now a length ruler so it's now
middle school geometry I know one side I
know an angle I could figure how far
away this pattern is and that lets us
infer the age of the universe so when we
say the universe is 13.7 seven billion
years old and we know that to about a
percent that's supposedly
measuring that size that's one of the
things we learn from these maps so
here's our measurements how 1'p things
are with scale versus angle and the
convention we plotted in is we plot it
in terms of angle to 180 degrees over
angle so this represents large scales
this represents small scales and this
shows the amplitude versus scale the
points represent our data you can see
there's a peak this is actually the
language the fact that we use to report
our data we talk among ourselves now
what should you was sort of stepping
back outside the field see from this
there's a couple thoughts one is a form
of reductionism we took that map which
was a million measurements in the sky
and we reduced it to a grass with a
couple hundred points and we were able
to capture most of the information in
that map in this curve in fact we could
actually show that all of the
statistically significant information
Mack once you've removed the galaxy is
basically in that curve second you'll
see a curve that fits the Veda and
that's a curve with a handful of Mach
number fit by a handful of numbers the
numbers have talked about the universe's
composition and age and how the
fluctuations behave and what's
remarkable is we can take the data fit
those numbers to this data and then
compare it to other data we have on the
age and structure of the universe and
all the pieces seem to fit together you
have a model like this that fits so well
the next step is to get more data and
the next step in getting data was the
Planck satellite the Planck satellite
was a European legend with very
significant contributions from the from
NASA from the US and it mapped the sky
at higher sensitivity and higher
precision and in order to make accurate
maps of the and removed the galaxies it
had not 5 frequencies but 9 frequencies
and it mapped things at these much
higher frequencies in which you see a
lot of emission from galactic dust and
by combining these multi frequency maps
Planck was able to make an even cleaner
map of the sky at higher resolution and
then again we can take that map and
represent the information in the map in
this spectrum and this is the amplitude
of fluctuations versus scale and I'll
come back to this plot later this is
actually both data from this experiment
data for map and experiment and data
from some ground-based experiments all
shown here and what you see is we've
gone to smaller scales we've gone this
is smaller scales here and as the data
improves the model same basic model
continues to fit the data so what do we
do next
we want even better data we want to go
to higher resolution
so what we've been doing with our group
as we've been kept building an
experiment and operating it in Chile
called the Atacama cosmology telescope
this is up in the Atacama Desert at
17,000 feet near the border between
Argentina Chile and Bolivia beautiful
spot and a wonderful place to operate
this telescope there's a picture of the
telescope zoomed in when I talk about
telescopes really should talk about
people right because when you do work
like this it takes a team of people and
it's this team that works together to
make this all happen and it really
requires a wide range of expertise
working together to enable us to get
this kind these kinds of results and
since I'm a New Haven I should highlight
Loren Newberg is a member of our team
Laura that has been deeply involved in
building the instrumentation these are
incredibly sensitive experiments we're
measuring fluctuations at the level of a
millionth of a degree and on the
theorists I just do the statistics it's
kind of easy relatively speaking I have
tremendous respect for my experimental
colleagues who make these complex
experiments work and Laura's been why
are the key people both on this current
experiment act and building the elec
electronics for reading out the data
from our upcoming experiment assignments
Observatory so what does this let us do
here's a piece of the Planck map here's
the same data taken from act you can see
that we see first the same sky that's
reassuring
you'd like to see the same experiment
this is just a piece of the map zoom in
and that the same that we see the same
things with W map and Planck and act and
it's a great experience that you've got
a consistent set of gaps and then you
can zoom in and see some of the details
and including something interesting
things like this is a cluster of
galaxies casting a shadow against the
microwave sky and now we can look at the
combined data and again this is
lumpiness versus scale the theory goes
through it beautifully and you can see
the blue points are from w map and the
black points are from Planck and they
lie right on top of each other and here
I think I see green is from the Atacama
and are in red is from the South Pole
and we've got a pretty consistent
picture so now that we've measured the
temperature we're going to now look at a
different kind of map and the rest of my
talk will be looking at different types
of maps we make now that we've done the
temperature map and the new things we're
learning from these new maps the next
type of map I want to talk about is
polarization
so first tactics remind you what
polarized light is white coming from the
Sun is unpolarized what do we mean by
that light comes towards us it has an
electric field the oscillates a magnetic
field that oscillates one polarization
of the Y coming towards you has this
electric field Direction another
polarization has this one and
unpolarized light has the same number of
photons with this polarization this
polarization this polarization they're
all all the same when light scatters
it's more likely to scatter with this
polarization or off a piece of metal or
a surface of the ocean or off clouds in
the sky than with others so when you
look out on a sunny day with clouds or
go to the beach you'll see that much of
the scattered light not the way coming
from the Sun but the diffusive glare is
polarized with the polarization
corresponding to this direction because
it's scattered off the Suns over there
it's scattered off the
surface and come towards you so if you
put on sunglasses that are polarized it
blocks this polarization and let's
through this polarization and that's how
my sunglasses work you can test this and
look a little stupid by taking your
sunglasses and rotating them and if
closing one eye and try using your
sunglasses rotated you'll find that it
makes things terrible you see basically
only the mostly glare and relatively
little normal light so that's why you
always want to wear your sunglasses this
way but there's information in that
polarized light because it's and does
the same process happens in the early
universe light comes in it scatters off
of electrons and it produces a pattern
of polarization we represent those
polarizations with these headless arrows
showing the direction of the electric
fields we look at the polarization
patterns they can be divided into two
types of patterns and we can make maps
in each pattern one pattern of lines are
anti-symmetric under reflection if I
take this pattern and I put it in the
mirror it flips and looks like this
pattern
so that's the b-type pattern it flips in
the mirror the e-type pattern stays the
same in the mirror you take that you
reflect it looks the same and you can
divide any pattern like this into mirror
symmetric and there are anti symmetric
and we can make two maps out of our
polarization measurements
eehm apps and B maps and they contain
different types of information the e
maps and here's the planck polarization
email and there's a couple things you
should see about this map notice it
doesn't have the fine resolution the
temperature map did
that's the polarization signal is weaker
and we have to smooth out all the
on small scales to see this now we'll
show you better polarization map soon
but you can see this overall pattern and
this is actually very interesting
complementary information because if the
temperature tells us primarily about the
density fluctuations near the universe
this is telling us primarily about
fluctuations in velocity and we're
tracing the large-scale velocities of
electrons with these measurements and if
our theory is correct then we should be
able to fit the density pattern and
predict the velocity pattern and we'll
you'll see we'll do that now this shows
let me see if I can pull up this movie
our new measurements this is data we've
just we haven't published yet or just so
if you can analyze this with your eye
quickly enough you can steal our results
this shows on the top an e pattern slice
of the mat from play a beat pattern from
plank here we're showing data measured
with our much more sense of experiments
in Chile are working at polarization and
the top is an e pattern and you can see
let's look at the top as our data
improves you can still see the same
underlying patterns emerge as you watch
them come across there now cleaner so in
this side here this is mostly signal
will over there there's significant
signal and noise when we look here the
early universe variations intent in
density generate only in patterns so we
expect there to be almost no B pattern
now there's some funny things coming in
even you're very observant you'll see
these little lines these little star
like patterns those are actually bright
radio sources that
have come in and here and what's
worrying us a bit is we're seeing
occasionally lines here which we thinks
are some pick up from the ground that we
haven't properly reduced so we're you
know we haven't written this is not a
hundred percent ready for prime time
for writing papers about but where this
is the kind of data we look at but these
be modes be patterns are are interesting
and we'll get to them sit for a moment
so here's our temperature measurements
complaint now we can take temperature
and polarization and look at the
correlations and patterns and this is
looking at when we see putting up one
circle on the temperature map looking at
the amplitude of fluctuations at the
same position averaging over a region
and polarization and this shows are the
Planck data in green are measurements in
purple and the curve is our theory and
what's nice here is we fit the theory to
the temperature data didn't change
anything got more data the polarization
maps and then fit it here and here's the
polarization of show polarization we
also know I guess I didn't put in
polarization polarization but they also
fit now one of the things that generate
a lot of excitement a few years ago was
a claim that there was a protection of B
modes graphic from the early universe
and this this work made the front page
of the New York Times the people
involved were already awarding
themselves a Nobel Prize and what they
had seen was this this is the bicep
experiment led by a group at Harvard and
they saw this pattern here that looked
like the curlicue pattern the b-mode
pattern and the reason people were so
excited was they thought this was the
first detection of gravitational waves
in the early universe that this
represented our glimpse into the
universe's first moments while the most
powerful tests we would have of the
universe's first moments it generated a
lot of excitement among the theorists
who made predictions all sorts of
interesting sociological lessons
newspaper lessons have actually spoken
at Princeton to the class of on science
and journalism about this because the
reporters were told not to talk to
anyone from competing science teams or
actually told do not talk to anyone at
Princeton about this result and instead
go right to the publisher many of us who
worked in this field for a while look
this and said this is one frequency it's
dust you saw how much galactic dust
there is in the temperature maps and we
were extremely nervous about this result
and when we reanalyzed that we showed it
was all dust and sometimes you just see
in the smudge so this is a great place
to put up this side you know this is
pandering but you know you're in New
Haven you get to bash Harvard you ought
to do it alright so we'll turn from
those polarization maps in the final
minute to talk about the new kinds of
maps were starting to make and we're
making now maps of the distribution of
mass of universe and to understand what
we're doing we have to go back to get
relativity and think about how matter
her face and if matter curved spaces
light goes past the Sun as the microwave
photons the cosmic background photons
travel from the early universe to our
experiment they're going to propagate
through the large-scale structure of the
universe they're going to propagate
through galaxies and the galaxies in
large-scale structure
distort the space and as it distorts
space it deflects the path that light
takes so it will distort the microwaves
image that distortion is actually most
striking and polarization because our
polarization pattern started out purely
purely symmetric and when you deflect
the paths you take that light pattern
you break the nice symmetry so we can
measure that effect and make a map of
the mass distribution and this picture
here
represents which we've not published yet
a slice so this is a slice of the sky
about 40 degrees across that's pretty
big slice and about 200 degrees wide and
this shows the large-scale distribution
of matter in the universe and this is a
two-dimensional projection of all the
matter in the universe between us in the
microwave background right where the
photons see everything it's an
integration over all of that path and
what's really striking so this is the
pattern of mass if we look in the
infrared where we see much of the light
from galaxies that's the integrated
light in the infrared so where we see
more light we see more mess and with
this you can see we can--we galaxies we
can see what's the correspondence
between the mass and the light and this
is one of the new types of maps we're
making we're able to make maps of the
large-scale distribution of mass and as
our measurements continue to improve
we'll have more more precise
measurements of the mass distribution
now we're doing this integrating mass
back to you know 13
a billion years ago there are other
experiments optical measurements also
measuring the distribution of mass by
looking at the effects on galaxies so
when we combine these we will able to be
able to make a three-dimensional map of
how matter is distributed in the
universe now there we go flashing back
and forth this is brand new data sources
fully after so at a few times we can
also measure the large-scale
distribution of pressure in the universe
this is Stewart effect called the
Sanjaya cell dovish effect the idea here
is that the photon comes into the
microwave background it hits the hot gas
in the cluster and the hot gas scatters
the photon up in energy that hasn't
entered a neat effect that at low
frequencies the cost so the this pattern
here is you put a cluster in front it
scatters photons up in energy so at low
energies low frequency that cluster
casts a shadow against the microwave
star and looks like a cold spot and I
showed you on the map some cold spots
and that intermediate frequencies it's a
dimmer cold spot here it has no effect
and it looks like a hot spot at high
frequencies because the photons have
been scattered from here to here so with
that we can use our multi frequency maps
to make a pressure map and this is a
piece of our first really hype
signal-to-noise pressure map that we
have using our multi frequency data we
can then go along and find the clusters
in the map and this shows a list of some
of our clusters the blue points come
from the planck map which is a
and we see a lot of the clusters in the
nearby universe are seen in Planck the
South Pole telescope is shown in orange
and they have a significant number of
clusters not quite as many as our new
sample we were doing the slightly
aggressive thing of plotting our ployed
ii so it ours come on top of theirs but
they actually have a very significant
contribution to and you can see all
these new clusters we've seen with our
measurements and what we will be doing
in the next couple years is learning a
great deal from the properties of these
clusters we will have data in the
microwave we will have all sky surveys
happening in the x-ray we have optical
surveys and by combining all these we
can use these clusters to watch how
structure grows and evolves and that
will give us we hope new insights into
the nature of dark energy and finally
we'll be able to map the gas ice oops I
wrote this on the train I was a little
tart gas momentum we can actually look
at that the velocities and the patterns
that way and we were able to make that
we don't have them yet so I won't really
focus on them but soon we will have
assignment observatories accurate
momentum Maps so let me conclude the
story I want to tell today is that about
how maps reveal the universe and what we
learn from the maps we've made of the
microwave background in the last couple
decades is a very simple but strange
picture one described by handful of
numbers that seem to fit a host of
astronomical data work our data
continues to improve there are always
some tensions as data improves and we'll
see as that continues to improve whether
that goes away or points to new physics
but overall it shows the universe states
both simple and strange and we've also
seen how the intervening universe
distorts the maps we don't have perfect
maps but
ones that are affected by what happened
between then and now and we can use that
those distortions as another way of
understanding we can use that as a way
of tracing the distribution of mass in
the universe the distribution of
momentum and the distribution of
pressure and use that to get new
insights into the universe's evolution
so for us maps are a very important way
of knowing and want to conclude this
here and thank you all for listening
[Applause]
thanks David for that excellent talk so
now we have time for a few questions and
we have a roaming microphone so please
go ahead and
if your maps are distorted by all the
intervening maths why does your theory
fit the temperature fluctuations so well
so the question mr. peel was if the
intervening matter distorts the maps why
does the theory fit the maps well some
of it is we know the amount of
distortion that we expect in the theory
so when we compute the theoretical
predictions of the theory we include
that distortion as part of the
theoretical prediction so we don't know
where the mass is but we know about the
theory predicts the amplitude averaged
over the universe of what the
fluctuation should be so in fact what it
does is it takes these peaks
particularly because you're distorting
worth angles it makes them a little bit
lower and raises the amplitude in the
valleys it kind of this distortion out
some of the patterns of the sound waves
we roughly see the level we expect and
the Planck that we actually see
distortions that are about 20% more than
we expect now that's within the
statistical errors so at about 5% of the
universe's you five percent of the
observers in the universe should see
that now this could be pointing to a
problem in our theory it could be
pointing to a problem in the analysis or
could be telling us you know just be a
statistical fluke I happen to be the
referee on this paper on the train ride
home one of my assignments is to finish
refereeing this paper and worry about
have they properly accounted for this
what information or speculations can you
share with us about properties of dark
matter and dark energy so let me first
begin with properties of dark matter I
can tell you first what well what we
know with some confidence is dark matter
is different from atoms so we know what
dark matter doesn't do the thing we know
that it does is cluster gravitationally
there's dark matter in galaxies it
responds to gravity seemingly the same
way atoms do and we can test that by
seeing how it behaves the universe our
predictions for the microwave background
would not work if the dark matter
responded differently to gravitation so
we know that it acts like atoms in
response to gravity we know that the
dark matter doesn't have electric charge
because it would then interact with
light and it doesn't seem to we know
that it doesn't have interact with
nuclei directly so we know it doesn't do
much ideas for what it is our very very
the most popular idea is that there's an
extension of what's called a standard
model of particle physics called
supersymmetry in supersymmetry every
particle has a partner that partner has
the same statistical properties of it
but is a more massive version of it the
electron has its partner thus electron
the quark has its partner thus quark the
photon has its partner the photino if
this theory is right and there's lots of
nice mathematical properties it took
easily an hour talk explaining
supersymmetry the lightest
supersymmetric particle should be stable
and we are looking for that particle one
of the major goals of the Large Hadron
Collider is to look for supersymmetry
one of the great disappointments
of for particle physics is we haven't
seen it yet and perhaps it's not there
to be seen one of its nice features is
it offers a nice Dark Matter particle
and we're looking directly for that as
well as undergrad experiments and
haven't seen it there are many other
particle candidates that people have
suggested so the most popular ideas is
broadly a new type of particle we
haven't seen yet dark energy the most
popular ideas is that empty space has
energy called vacuum energy and that
vacuum energy is what's causing the
acceleration we don't understand why the
vacuum energy would have the value it
does it would seem to imply some deep
connection between quantum mechanics and
general relativity that we don't
understand yet other ideas for the dark
energy is that there ought to be a field
that feels fills all space and there's
energy associated with that field now it
seems strange to have a field that fills
all space except for one of the things
we've learned is the existence of the
Higgs field which we've now observed
directly and the Higgs field the field
that fills all space we don't think the
Higgs field as we understand it is
responsible for the dark energy but one
possibility that gets a lot of attention
is that there's a field that fills all
space that's interacts weakly with
itself and we're seeing its effects in
the dark energy depending on the dark
and what the dark energy is will
determine the universe's fate and one
possibility is that dark energy is
strength is growing with time if that is
happening that will make the universe
accelerate faster and faster and
eventually tear the universe up in a big
rip I was asked by new scientists about
this a number of years ago this was back
in November early November 2016 and
there was then data still is data for
measurements of the expansion rate of
the universe the Hubble constant that
showed a discrepancy between the
measurements we infer from the microwave
background and what we measure locally
using the Hubble telescope miss
discrepancy people call the Hubble
tension I was asked to comment on the
idea that someday the universe will be
torn up in a big way and my comment at
the time in early November 2016 was I
viewed the big rip is of something like
the Trump presidency it was possible it
was frightening
but I don't think it's going to happen
so based on my prognostic ability I
think the universe is going to be
destroyed in the big rift at about a
couple billion years
David you mentioned comparing CMB
measurements to optical distributions of
galaxies there are also a number of new
experiments doing H 1 hydrogen
measurements which penetrate farther
than the optical telescopes can can you
say something about comparing to those
yeah so one of the hopes is that we can
look at the pattern of fluctuations seen
in neutral hydrogen and high redshift
and use that the fluctuations the h1 as
a way to probe the large-scale
distribution of matter in the universe
in principle there's the ability to
learn a tremendous amount from those h1
measurements I think in practice that we
will begin by learning a great deal
about how the first stars and galaxies
formed so the first thing we will learn
from h1 and this will be very important
and is how the first stars and galaxies
emerged but we'll see how the gas is
heated by the first stars measuring from
the h1 the fluctuations at this kind of
this level of precision I think will be
extremely challenging right now we've
measured well close to 2500 modes that
squared modes on the sky so we've
measured the amplitude of fluctuations
to a part in 2500 in order to the h1
observations to make a significant
contribution to our understanding they
will have to make measurements with this
precision and remember we have
polarization measurements will make soon
at this precision the challenge for the
h1 measurements is they have to remove
the signal from the galaxy and you've
seen that was a challenge for the CMB
wasn't so bad for the temperature we
just cut it was mostly in the Galactic
plane but already for B modes you saw
that it caused problems for h1 the range
of redshifts and which is interesting
the four grounds are a million times
brighter than the signal now they're
smooth
helps us remove them but you've got to
remove something not by a factor of a
million which is as the level that the
people working on it think they need to
do but if you want those fluctuations
you want to characterize the
fluctuations at a part in a thousand to
be able to give interesting information
you need to remove them by a part in a
billion and I think that's gonna be very
challenging so I I think it's I view it
as something that is worth doing but not
something that I would personally work
on but I think it's going to be much
harder than those who advocate for it
imagine yes I may be you hit on it but I
missed the significance of the size of
the clumps in your in your map at the
age 380,000 years what do we learn about
the universe from the size of the clumps
at that age so I think the right
physical picture to have oops
is this Soundwave okay go there we go
so the size of the lumps correspond to
how far off the Soundwave does so by
measuring the size of that the lumps
that's nature holding up a ruler this is
about 380,000 light years roughly that
ruler and we know the angle so that size
gives us the age of the universe we
could also see a relationship between
cold spots and hot rings by looking at
the amplitude of that central peak which
is caused by the dark matter and this
which doesn't move and the ring which is
caused by the electrons protons and
photons that relative amplitude gives us
the declaration of density and Adams the
density and dark matter we've measured
that but the power factor five and we've
measured that very precisely by
measuring that ratio the thickness of
this ring is due to the
see how the electrons and photons move
relative to each other
when we convert this statistically into
this plot the age of the universe comes
from the position of that peak which is
the characteristic size the density of
atoms and matter comes for the ratio of
the first peak to the second peak
because that's the ratio that peak that
first peak to the ring around it and
this the Klein on small scales high L
depends on the diffusion of photons
relative to electrons and that gives us
the density of atoms so we actually fit
a complicated set of codes to do it but
basically you can pull it off by eye
from this part and if you're really good
at analyzing by eye the map just from
the spot size and how they're how fuzzy
they are you can read off the parameters
thank you David so much for an
illuminating talk showing us how
inference from maps is really a part and
parcel of cosmology today and the
prospects for the future thanks everyone
for coming please join us for a
reception now in room 108 down the
corridor
[Applause]
[Music]